yeah so i understand what you're saying
when when you when you say that you miss
doing the physical stunts because here i
knew not to do that and
and how long were you out for when you
passed out
you know like it did
for like a minute or so you know the
duration of time that you're knocked
unconscious is a lot like uh the height
of bridges any [ __ ] whoever jumped
off at 20 foot bridge says oh man it was
100 feet you know like
and anybody's ever been knocked
unconscious oh man it was minutes five
minutes to it but like you timed the the
book yeah i i specifically timed the
ball and it was like about a minute five
seconds just because i want to know
right i want to know what happened to me
and um
uh
god there was a point that everybody
everybody was saying that you were out
for like five minutes no that's not true
it probably feels like that when you're
like is he gonna wake back up you have
no idea if you're knocked out you have
no concept of time right sure the only
way to know for sure is to go back and
watch the footage yeah because
my memory was erased for a little bit um
what's the difference when you pass out
like snoring or not snoring is like
snoring you're [ __ ] out
the doctor says you're trying to swallow
your tongue um so
yeah cause you didn't snore did you i
snored with the bull and i snored with
butterbean yeah i don't know if you
snore on the treadmill i i i couldn't
tell you i i don't have any idea but i
will say about the treadmill
it could have been less
that the results could have been a
little better for our heads but there
was a pad down right before we filmed
like a
rubber mat down
and i just said lose it for sure because
it's just when you see pads on the
jackass set it doesn't work and right do
i regret it
no
you know we're all okay but i have to
maintain the sure remember after that
dave england called me up he's like hey
dude just a heads up like steve hit his
head pretty hard
meanwhile i got text from steve booking
a tour to austin and he's like now i'm
like wait a minute what's going on here
you had this whole tour going on you're
like okay let's get this guy on the road
and i'm like
dave just told me that you were out and
yeah i'm
hardest working man in show business
right here for sure
yeah dude